les cerises sur printemps cela fait du
brendan à six mois
oui je sais mais le temps que j'arrive
et samira des histoires courtes et
amusante pour ces vacances de noël le
petit moulin des vaux de cernay a invité
une conteuse et la période et peut
trouver on associe les comptes annuels
parce que peut-être voilà dans
l'imaginaire déjà le merveilleux les
rassemble mais ce que nous disent les
comptes c'est que le merveilleux est
partout toujours tout le temps et sur le
veut bien
c'est tous les jours noël une petite
salle est dédiée aux contes pour une
intimité loin du musée
le moulin propose des activités ludiques
en plus de l'aspect historique et cette
première a du succès elle s'était bien
j'ai bien aimé toutes les histoires et
j'ai mis à chanter j'aime et ont chanté
trois séances de contes ont été proposés
il centaines de personnes petits et
grands en a profité peut-être pour faire
passer le temps plus vite
et oui plus que quelques jours à
patienter